kim kardashian is now legally single and
wants her estranged husband kanye west
to leave her boyfriend pete davidson
alone a source tells e.t the beauty
mogul is now hoping the rapper will move
on from publicly mentioning her or pete
after a judge granted kim to be declared
legally single and have her maiden name
restored it's a different experience for
sure
but that didn't stop yay's most recent
public antic
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
and my new bed
i know illuminati man
that's the grammy winners music video
for his song easy and kanye makes his
feelings for the snl star known the clip
features distorted claymation figures in
a dark sequence which includes a moment
yay kidnaps a clay figure that looks
eerily similar to pete there it is
there was don't interrupt
and if that wasn't clear enough the
video ends with the phrase flashing
across the screen that reads everyone
lived happily ever after except skeet
you know who of course the name ski is
kanye's nickname for pete but don't
worry yay adds jk he's fine making sure
that you all are entertained
well it seems kim is not happy with the
yeezy designer's actions the source
tells e.t kim is upset because pete has
been nothing but kind and continues to
be brought into kanye's drama and he
doesn't deserve it the couple is very
happy and hopefully over time kanye will
come to terms that kim being happy is
all that matters and despite yay's
latest hit against pete the skim's
founder is showing support for her man
oh my god thursday morning kim liked
this praise of pete from filmmaker james
gunn on twitter which reads quote for
the record pete davidson is one of the
nicest sweetest guys i know a truly
generous tender and funny spirit he
treats everyone around him with respect
i love that but through all this kim
ultimately wants to speed up their
divorce in the best interest of their
four children north saint chicago and
psalm while appearing in court on
wednesday the judge asked the reality
star how the kids were doing kim
responded with everyone is doing okay
and when asked if she's having fun with
the kids the proud mama replied so much
fun and noted that four children is a
lot but it's the best and i do have
you know a family that i have to just be
positive and get it together for and at
the end of the day kanye also agrees in
a statement to et the jesus walks rapper
says quote i've asked my team to
expedite the dissolution of my marriage
to kim so i can put my entire attention
to our beautiful children
[Music]
you